[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Roundtable your very favorite weekly
Libertarian news chat
brought to you by the magazine free
minds and free markets I am Matt Welch
joined by Nick Gillespie Peter suterman
and Catherine mengu Ward Mary week
between Christmas and New Year's present
Audi 2023 almost Happy Holidays yes oh
yes wow someone's been batching eggnogs
over there
those that really sounds like a
disturbing euphemism man yeah I think it
sounds like PornHub uh sub vertical
totally good things to be batching
eggnogs is to be in a good place no
um perhaps uh as you can already tell
I've been matching something that
sounded creepy yeah
um not as creepy as is Star Wars slank
it or whatever he was talking about
before we hit the record button this is
as you can already tell perhaps a very
special year-end episode of the recent
Roundtable we're going to put down that
microscope boy and go a big picture take
a look at what were our biggest stories
or news developments of the year that is
fading as we speak what we foresee as
the biggest stories potentially of 2023
and what we got wrong and right last
time we conducted this exercise one year
ago Nick Gillespie you're a doctor uh
let's start with you since the story
that you're choosing
for uh I'm just gonna I'm not gonna let
you talk so uh you keep trying
yeah so my biggest story is uh Madam we
we as you mentioned we talked about this
uh you know Ad nauseam but I think that
we are
um we witnessed the end of an era on the
internet and the beginning of something
new uh I don't know if it's better but
it is going to be more dispersed more
fractured more fragmented and hopefully
more liberated uh including older
platforms but uh in the past year meta
became the equivalent of Sears Roebuck
uh you know once uh once a uh robust uh
presence in American Commerce and
American culture to just becoming you
know an empty uh you know store
collapsing in on itself
um uh Twitter has not you know Twitter
was a hellscape before Elon Musk bought
it it remains that
um but it seems like it's getting better
uh because musk is probably going to be
gone by the time we even publish this
podcast he might be gone he's said that
he's going to leave but it invigorated a
a platform that had been dying
um I think the biggest thing to look at
is uh you know things like Tick Tock
their growth rate of tick tock declined
massively over the past year
um suggesting that it too is not growing
in the way that it was and instead what
I think we're going to be seeing uh our
our more service oriented uh platforms
like LinkedIn which continues to grow
and you don't hear really anything bad
about LinkedIn uh what you hear about it
is that it is phenomenally good at what
it does which is a targeted
employment-based kind of uh you know
showcase for people there's news and
things like that and some people get
very big on LinkedIn but it doesn't have
the content moderation issues because
it's more focused
um I think you are going to see people
leaving not necessarily for Mastodon
which is is a decentralized Federation
of kind of many twitters Jack Dorsey has
a new project which is getting high
marks from people like Mike masnick at
Tech dirt and things like that but I
think what we are what we witnessed in
2023 was the end of the old new media
and the beginning of the new New Media
it's not going to be web 3 and it is not
necessarily going to be in the news that
much but the people who use the internet
the people who buy the internet or run
the internet and create the internet are
busy uh being born and I think that's
the single biggest story of last year
and it's good that we closed out with
the Twitter files where there's a lot to
talk about there are a lot to critique
the way it was done as well as also to
go through the information but by
exposing how much the government
interacts with major Tech platforms
which were all born in a moment where we
were finally escaping the clutches of of
you know of terrestrial meet space and
the the hulking rotting corporations and
governments that John Perry Barlow
talked about in his Declaration of
cyberspace in in the mid 90s
um that has been revealed and that is
going to be the next thing that we move
into uh an Internet that actually gets
back to the kind of ideals of the mid
90s when the web was being born
Catherine I mean it's weird or it's
striking right um our great colleague
robbery Suave had a book panic attack
right about um about uh Tech uh that
came out I don't know when like a year
ago or so tact Panic Tech Panic they all
have the word panic in them but they're
different Arrangements yeah
um at any rate uh we began the year with
like a widespread bipartisan sense of
like wow we really need to do something
about these monopolies all of them
and yeah all these monopolies in the
same industry you need to get we need to
whittle it down to at least three or
four
when do we get to spike the football and
say say we're we're always right people
listen to us
I mean we we never get to spike the
football I regret to inform you like we
are always Charlie Brown and never Lucy
or something to mix my football
metaphors sometimes we get to spike the
eggnog at best we're spiking eggnog but
but yeah we were right and you know I do
think I'm a little bit torn because I
think that there are people who say uh
with some justice yeah you know these
large powerful corporations these
dominant players in a certain industry
sure they're going to go away eventually
but what harm have they done in the
meantime
and you Libertarians are too utopian to
think that they will go away in some way
that like correlates with the harm that
they do but then here we are having a
national moment of like actually a bunch
of these social media platforms are kind
of bad we'll stop using them like this
is what this is exactly the dynamic that
people who understand markets and
understand particularly the ways that
they work
um in contrast to governments which is
to say
it can all turn on a dime when the cost
benefit no longer works and that isn't
true with with the actions of the state
so yeah people were like oh no is
Twitter bad and Elon was like oh no is
Twitter bad I'm gonna buy it and see if
I can fix it and then he was like nope
actually maybe it just is bad no matter
what and everyone's like yeah it could
be bad no matter what and then everyone
just leapt off the side of the boat and
like swam off into the beautiful Crystal
Seas like it's fine it's gonna be fine
and maybe Twitter emerges you know still
alive still
somewhat intact from whatever is
happening here always worth keeping in
mind that Twitter was never real life
and everyone was not on Twitter just
everyone we know therefore again making
it not the Public Square and not a
monopoly um Facebook has already I can't
even remember what Facebook looks like I
haven't seen it in so long and
um other bad social media will go the
same way Peter do you you live in
Washington
um do you uh ever foresee this uh sudden
kind of like uh loss of hold on
everyone's Consciousness I mean I I
shouldn't say that really because people
have been talking Non-Stop about Twitter
and nothing else for the last month it's
very annoying actually but it's sort of
like the loss of hold on on America of
these social media platforms doing
anything to slow down what has been a
race in Washington to regulate these
people that's a good question I think
that it may change some of the
discussions in Congress but first we're
going to have to get through something
that I was going to preview a little
later in this episode a Supreme Court
case dealing with Section 230 and that's
going to come next year and that's going
to be a big deal and we can talk a
little bit more about that later but I
think that we're going to have to get
through that first and
nine months from now the discussion
about social media and how to regulate
it whether to regulate it what section
230 is good for or not that discussion
in Washington is just going to be very
different because the Supreme Court will
probably will have heard the case
and uh and we'll probably have ruled and
uh because because social media will
look so different nine months from now
and in part that's because we're gonna
see the sort of the maybe not the end
stage of the Elon Musk vision of Twitter
but we are going to see the development
of it right it's gonna be it's gonna be
a a fully grown you know or at least
like an adolescent right it's not going
to be this kind of Mason already in the
womb right because we don't because Elon
Musk has owned Twitter for such a short
time right now that we we really don't
know what the sort of day-to-day
operational uh vision of he has for it
is going to look like unless his plan is
simply to play emperor of Twitter for
the rest of his life which I think even
he will get bored by and then we're also
gonna be looking at a world in which
fewer and fewer people are on Facebook
and Facebook is very obviously not the
uh the not the Monopoly that uh a lot of
its critics have been claiming that it
is for a long time now we of course on
this podcast have been saying Facebook
is obviously not a monopoly for years
um but it's now become apparent I think
to to critics at the same time uh we're
also going to be looking at a world in
which Tick Tock is on the rise and we're
already seeing
um we're already seeing a lot of press
interest in Tick Tock uh in its in the
China Connections in the in its you know
that whether or not the folks affiliated
with bite dance it's the tick tocks
um parent company will disavow Chinese
you know uh the Communist party uh you
know uh atrocities right like whether
they're going to say oh actually it's
bad that they put uyghurs in
concentration camps that sort of thing
and I think that that's going to be a
very different sort of political
conversation than we've had about
Facebook because ultimately Facebook is
uh with people's complaint about
Facebook is that it's crappy
right like it's it's annoying like
that's that's just and it's big but it's
an American company and it's not
obviously you know uh it doesn't have
any obvious direct connection to Chinese
Communist party uh human rights abuses
and that may be different when it comes
to technology all right next up go ahead
I uh just uh kind of follow up on that
the low low standards there just so
incredible like oh there's no genocide
in this social media platform so it's uh
okay you know there are already
alternatives to tick tock and as I
mentioned their growth rate uh drop
significantly from like 30 year over
year to something like eight or six
percent I suspect if Congress or if the
government and they will start they've
already started the attack and this is
happening in the media of saying that
Tick Tock is a Chinese Communist Party
government agency uh and let's say they
ban it uh certain States and governments
the federal government doesn't want
federal employees on it and things like
that assume all of that happen happens
that energy will go someplace else and I
the Supreme Court case is interesting
but I think what we're going to see is a
ruling on an Internet that we have kind
of moved out of mostly
um and I'll also extend this a little
bit because I'll and I'll talk about
this later uh when we talk about what we
thought was the most important thing we
consumed in the past year but even with
Bitcoin you know Bitcoin which is the
ultimate kind of peer-to-peer
decentralized uh you know kind of
technology or currency and things like
that what I think we saw in 2023 was
both uh you know in a very tight bear
Market a terrible bear Market people
still stuck with it
um and we are starting to see the
beginning of the end of the exchanges
because the FTX
Scandal that closed out this year is
also a scandal ultimately about
centralization and of giving your keys
giving your uh giving your the thing you
own most whether it's your data or your
money or your currency or whatever to a
centralized organization that's going to
speed up the adoption of people actually
who use Bitcoin and other forms of
crypto to hold their keys themselves
which is the point
um so I think 2023 is going to be a
fantastic year for re-decentralization
all right next I I guess I would just
say that I think that the future of
social media is fragmentation even more
than decentralization you know so we
will probably see some social media
protocols that are based on something
you know decentralized where we already
have with Mastodon but that it's just
that instead of having a couple of
social media platforms or you know the
sites that that most people use they're
just going they're going to be dozens
and dozens of them and especially for
younger users we're just going to see
people sort of move out into into social
media like social media isn't going to
go away but but instead of everybody
being on Facebook or everybody being on
Tick Tock it's going to be that some
people are on be real and some people
are on gas and sometimes people are on
be real for six months and then it it
goes away and it's actually going to
look a lot like the market for say uh
gyms or or bars or right places that
people go to associate with each other
and engage in sort of in conversation
and shared activities and we will be
going wherever a different world we will
be going to wherever our mother doesn't
know about yet
um well put uh let's go next on our uh
roulette wheel of Stories of the year
and the ball uh lands on me
I got to do that
um oh my God Story of the Year Wild Ride
uh is uh Russia's brutal invasion of
Ukraine it's kind of back to uh front of
mind uh conversations in Washington
after uh president zielinski's address
to Congress and uh press conference with
Joe Biden and whatnot but it's kind of a
big deal when a nuclear-armed country
launches a major land war in Europe
um against uh an overmatched but very uh
Plucky and at this point very well
funded country sitting there
um it's hard to pin down exact estimates
on uh how much damage has been caused
but whatever the number is it's like
horrendous too horrendous to think about
on both sides there's uh right now
they're
um kind of settling on a consensus
number of a hundred thousand troops
killed or wounded on each side at this
point it's such a higher number
than than
what was produced for instance in the
Soviet Union's invasion of Afghanistan
in the 80s which had huge repercussions
on the politics back in Moscow so one
can only imagine especially as the the
uh very noticeable kind of resulting
clamp down on civil society in Russia
this year as part of the war what kind
of reverberations this might have at
least 20 000 civilians killed in Ukraine
as we speak and as we are talking
Russia sending Rockets into Power
stations and civilian infrastructure
targets trying to turn off all the power
and lights in a very cold country during
winter just appalling they've been on
the order of 15 million people displaced
made into refugees about half of whom
have crossed the border mostly into
Europe uh the other half are sort of
running around within Ukraine brain
itself destroyed at least 140 000
buildings and it's just a it's a crazy
number and it's changed the politics and
security assumptions of Europe Finland
and Sweden were never going to join NATO
and now they're going to very soon
they've applied to part of that process
certainly
the uh
enthusiasm of countries along the
periphery of Russia has increased about
wanting to join
um I think that would be a bad idea for
NATO to do but table that aside it
certainly has let people have a sense of
the importance of having security
guarantees from a defensive point of
view also it just has a huge potential
of what is this going to mean for
China's designs on Taiwan does it make
it more likely or less likely I think
it's it's very probable that it makes it
less likely after China sees how the
world uh rallied to the defense of a
country that is invaded by a big
neighbor it's just inherently
sympathetic to root for the person who's
invaded in that case the principle of
national sovereignty is not a small one
it's kind of a big one there's been a
lot of
reasons given particularly by the United
States over the last 30 years to justify
or attempt to justify usually very badly
and disastrously uh intervention into
another country we intervened to Libya
because we were trying to prevent a
local atrocity for example this is a
little bit different this is right there
on the order of uh when Iraq tried to
gobble up Kuwait
um the International Community has a
different set of taboos when it comes to
hey I'm just gonna Annex my neighbor
um and so it's going to have effects the
likes of which we don't really know I
presume that at some point in the next
year we're going to see Ukraine drive
basically Russia out of everywhere
except Crimea and then that moment will
be a very interesting one because the
interests of
the United States which is the principal
backer of Ukraine and Ukraine will maybe
differ in trying to wind that to a close
but it's a huge story it could be
Vladimir Putin's last act major act um
and it's a big failing act uh as
President of Russia and we don't know
what the world looks like coming out on
the other side of that my hope
um reflected in the piece I wrote
earlier this year right at the outset of
the war
um was that this would be an occasion
for a rethinking of the security status
in Europe and basically the creation of
a real post-cold war settlement which we
never really had usually after long Wars
there's a really big messy process of
creating a new international structure
of how things go
um I have argued that uh there should be
one like that and it should be led by
Europeans not the United States not the
United States primary involvement in it
uh helps to prolong and make things
worse not better that hope so far has
been dashed the U.S has been even more
Primary in this and I think that's a
mistake and one that will continue to uh
watch uh as uh Russia eventually loses
but on what terms we don't know suderman
are you still scared about us all dying
in a nuclear conflagration as you were
uh eight months ago I mean it depends on
the hour honestly and this but I do
think we just under rate the possibility
that this becomes a nuclear uh that this
becomes a nuclear uh war and that that
Putin just decides he's tired of losing
and he just wants to take out the enemy
using the resources that he has
um and I think the United States
involvement in Ukraine again Ukraine's I
I just have to keep repeating this
Ukraine Ukraine's cause is just
Ukraine is uh is absolutely the
sympathetic country here and I get why
people root for them to beat back Russia
I get why people want to help but
the sort of
the the sort of um joint activity that
we have seen
between the United States and Ukraine
with zelenski's appearance in Washington
with Biden essentially promising
unlimited resources make America if not
an active player I mean if not you know
actively fighting in the war we are a
partner in this war and that is a very
dangerous position to be in globally
because that means that that two of the
most uh most well-armed nuclear powers
in on the on the planet are effectively
at war with each other and I think you
just have to be you have to be at least
somewhat concerned about that all the
time even if it hasn't gone badly yet
even if in some ways aside from
obviously the initial Invasion itself uh
Ukraine has done surprisingly well and
we have beaten back Russian you know the
Ukraine and using United States uh
weapons has beaten back Russian forces
and degraded the Russian military you
have to be concerned and a little bit
worried that this thing
um this thing could could become a much
wider and much more deadly War I uh
worry Matt that
um you know American you know my my main
interest in Ukraine is the way that it
affects uh American foreign policy in
America and America and
um I uh well I agree with Peter that
Ukraine is you know incredibly
sympathetic is wholly sympathetic here
and is fighting a good fight it is not
America's and we have pivoted from
completely disastrous foreign policy not
just in terms of military intervention
but in terms of large strategy of our
role in the world we've pivoted from
Iraq and Afghanistan in 20 plus years of
absolute disaster and failure where
we've inflicted countless casualties and
deaths in Mayhem and Chaos on the planet
to this good War
um where we don't know what we're doing
we don't know what we've gotten into
um and that deeply worries me because
this is already a moral Crusade uh and
as as Peter suggested it's uh an
unlimited plan check as long as Joe
Biden is around and that should trouble
everybody because we need to figure out
how do we stop this and get back to
something you were talking about which
is an actual post-war settlement where
Europe is taking care of Europe and kind
of holding the order there and it's not
up to the U.S the upside and this goes
with my interest in kind of
decentralization and whatnot is the act
of Ukraine a relatively small country
with essentially no Armed Forces has
done incredibly well against one of the
very largest armies uh you know on the
planet that will give pause to not
hopefully to Russia I mean as the you
know Russians figure out a way to to
depose uh Putin or to change his
rhetoric so that he's ready to take
whatever scrap is given him and get out
but it's going to affect China I think
um which is all to the good and you know
that's a sign of a different world when
you know small all countries can
effectively Stave off invasions by
massively better armed uh you know
nations in what should have been a
walkover but the other thing is that the
longer this goes on uh the more likely
it is that Russia wins even if even if
it bleeds that Country Dry and Catherine
does this awaken your inner Romanian
your uh your inner neocon or your inner
anarchist
you know uh it's it's all Matt I contain
multitudes so yes is the answer to your
question
um no when when I chat with or consume
the content of my neocon pals
um you know I'm always struck by the
sincerity of their belief in the Justice
of the cause of the ukrainians and their
belief that the justice of that cause
creates a moral imperative for the
United States like that it's a coherent
system it's a coherent ethical system
it's just it just relies on some
assumptions that in the end I don't
share and it relies on I think and this
is the anarchist bit an Erasure of
the fact that
us you know the U.S supporting that war
is done at the expense of
you know at the very very least just a
higher rate of Taxation
um whether on the current generation or
future generations to pay off debt
um
and you know I think also at the at some
risk to the physical safety of Americans
as suterman has highlighted like when we
when we get nuked
um the the calculations all change so
you know I
I remain in the do you think taxes are
bad now uh wait till after the
apocalypse
um so my my position kind of Remains the
Same which which is very similar to to
to all y'alls I think which is like I'm
sympathetic to those guys and also I
don't I don't think that there that we
are required to help them nor do I think
as a matter of
um statecraft that it is even
praiseworthy to help them necessarily
um those are two different things and
people love to conflate them but um you
know I am not sure we are doing the
world a favor or ourselves a favor in
you know getting so heavily involved in
this conflict not least because you end
up with just these this kind of kind of
shenanigans that we got in our budget
process this week right which is like oh
we gave away all our weapons to the
ukrainians we got we need a lot of money
for more weapons and then we're gonna
have a lot more weapons and then we're
gonna give them away to somebody else
and like that's not a business that we
should be in I don't think uh all right
let's go next on our stories of the year
uh uh Roundtable
um
thank you uh suiterman what do you got
my story of the year is Biden's student
loan uh student debt cancellation it is
a flagrantly illegal 500 billion dollar
executive branch overreach at the behest
of progressive activists and lawmakers
and I think it's really indicative of
the Biden approach to governance and to
politics it is a policy that primarily
benefits its upper middle class
obviously educated or more educated than
most people borrowers if they've been to
college even for a couple of years
folks who are either better off than uh
on average than most people or upwardly
mobile it is just incredibly costly four
or five hundred billion dollars and
that's on top of the 200 billion dollars
or so uh that that has we've already
incurred just from pausing repayment uh
on student loans as part of uh pandemic
policy it's inflationary in a time of
high inflation and again it is just
blatantly flagrantly obviously illegal
to the point where a year prior to Biden
doing this Nancy Pelosi was like oh yeah
we can't do that it would be illegal and
they Justified it by an absurd frankly
insulting reading of a post 911 statute
that has been rejiggered to fit the
facts of the pandemic the heroes Act
Right which is you know another lesson
in whenever you have a cutesy acronym
attached to your legislation it's a bad
idea but that was the higher education
relief opportunities for students act
which basically said that that first
responder types
um after 9 11 that the president could
uh could adjust or cancel some of their
student loans but it also just sort of
had some vague language about emergency
about times of emergency and so the
Biden Administration went back and said
oh this is a time of emergency because
you know there's a pandemic this was of
course as the pandemic was winding down
um so we're just going to use that to
basic to it's not quite spending in the
way that Congress spends money but it
but the cost to to Americans through the
federal government is about four or five
hundred billion dollars and we're going
to use that to pass a four or five 500
or 500 billion dollar program a half
trillion dollars here just illegally and
uh and and it's again this is just a
giveaway to to Progressive activists
um and to uh to upper middle class
upwardly mobile Democrats it's insulting
it's embarrassing
um and I'm I'm glad that the Supreme
Court is actually going to take a look
at this I think it is likely at this
point that this policy ends up um being
struck down uh you'd like to eat class
war for breakfast
um I also I uh had a total of about ten
thousand dollars out in student loans
still
I know but uh you know but when I
finished by the time I finished my
doctoral program did I mention that I
have a PhD thank you uh for uh for
reminding us so uh should yeah should I
have repaid your student loans
absolutely because you dropped out so
you lose I stayed in I win that's
clearly no uh you know Peter is right uh
uh about it's a major story I think it
is revealing of uh a Biden biden-esque
approach by denovian wow approach to
politics
um the one question I have uh for uh
Peter is do you think did did that
programmer the announcement of the
relief did it have any meaningful effect
on the midterms because one of the
things that was fascinating is that the
polling seemed to be all over the place
uh of whether or not you know apart from
all of the serious questions about it
like was it gonna help the Democrats in
the midterms or not and I read stuff
that you know showed probably not but
maybe I don't know
my read on that is that it may have had
a small effect but it probably wasn't a
significant one that the midterms went
better than expected for Democrats
primarily because of uh Republican
candidate quality issues which is to say
the Republicans just ran a bunch of
morons
I like it that you said that in both
languages
convenient for our listeners
I think and [ __ ] is uh you know rapidly
becoming a scientific or a political
science category for Republican
candidates uh Catherine briefly if you
will uh what's the ideal uh anarchotopia
version of the student loan process
it's it's we don't even have to be like
idealistic or anarchotopic about this
it's just the way that loans work for
literally everything else where you need
a loan like there's a market in them the
banks provide them or non-banks provide
them I would be delighted to uh you know
loosen up some of those regulations but
you know when I was in college I took
out student loans as well
and I had a patchwork of student loans
so I had some that were subsidized some
that were private and you know we have
all of these incredible tools to predict
the likelihood that a loan will get paid
back now do those tools work every time
no see 2008 but the uh the likelihood
that a loan will be paid back and which
helps determine the size of an
appropriate loan and the rate of the uh
that people should pay on those loans
just do that it would be we I don't
understand like people would get so much
more information about their educational
spending choices if we let prices convey
that information and this is not like
wackadoodle utopianism this is just how
every other
loan system works like you can't buy a
Mercedes if you want to get a car loan
and you don't have a job and you're just
like reading books about
art history that like you're not going
to get the car loan that's appropriate
the same should be true for education I
love me some liberal arts education
people who want an MFA like actually
Catherine college is good and he's not
wrong in many cases but going into
massive amounts of debt that you can't
pay back is bad is really really bad for
people and we have figured out how to
make it worse Joe Biden has figured out
how to make it worse by generating an
additional layer of catastrophic
uncertainty around whether or not you
will have to pay that back which is the
only thing worse than having huge
student loan debt that you shouldn't
have taken out in the first place all
right Catherine let's double dip with
you what is your story of 2022 so my big
story of 2022 is the Dobbs ruling and
its Fallout
um this is a big deal
um and this is something that I had I
made a prediction uh on this matter uh
you know a year prior I I would I was
would have been wrong I did not think
that um abortion rights would fall in
this country in this way it was a shock
to many people's systems it was a shock
to mine I do think we were in a kind of
interesting quiet period right now on
Dobb's politics
so everybody lost their minds when the
ruling was first leaked and then
formally issued
and
I believe that it is going to be quite a
big deal in our national kind of
political conversation and political
economy candidates will be running on
a wide variety of nuanced positions on
abortion now there's a world in which
that's good
um that like the stupid discourse of
like I'm pro-choice or I'm pro-life and
it's all signaling because we're
constrained by Roe anyway
um was not really good for anyone
however
um that is like a small Silver Lining on
a very very dark cloud which is that
there are now just Millions more women
in this country who have incredibly
diminished access to what I think should
be
um something that is solely up to their
discretion and the discretion of their
medical providers so um you know there's
lots of different ways to quantify this
but one that um that I've seen around is
that
um now something like a third of the
women in the country
um of kind of childbearing age are more
than an hour from an abortion provider
and that is because if you live in one
of the states that either had a trigger
law and so therefore as soon as Dobbs
came down abortion access was restricted
or have subsequently
um passed laws to restrict access
those P those people either can't get an
abortion or you know more relevantly
have to travel I do think it's an
interesting experiment in federalism and
from that perspective
um you know I am intrigued to follow how
it goes because it is true that
um you know I think there will be
broader patterns where people who value
having access to abortion will move to
places that have it and vice versa I
think this is probably a bad thing for
polarization in the country if you're if
that is your primary concern we're going
to sort more red and more blue but yeah
I guess I just like I think
here we are we're a Libertarian podcast
of course there are Libertarians who are
pro-life um and it's always important to
acknowledge those because otherwise we
get a bunch of annoyed emails so here
you go annoyed emailers some
Libertarians are pro-life but uh I think
on a Libertarian podcast wrapping up
2022 to not talk about
this big new prohibition right like we
are now entering like a new prohibition
era in many many states which will have
all of the predictable consequences that
prohibitions have I think that the word
prohibition applies here in large part
because people disagree about abortion
we don't say there's a Prohibition on
murder except for in the most technical
sense because we all agree don't do
murder but this country is very very
divided about
where abortion falls on uh on that you
know on that kind of on those moral
questions and because of that there will
be people at odds with their police
there will be people at odds with their
neighbors there will be secrecy there
will be black markets and we know how
all that goes and it's it's dark so
that's to me is the biggest thing that
happened
with respect to freedom in the United
States at least in 2022. hey Catherine
you mentioned the quietness of the
current political discourse you called
it a moment but I wonder do you think
that quietness that currently is
happening vindicates in some ways the
anti-row argument that overturning Roe
would cool the debate and de-escalate
the culture War surrounding that's an
important question no because I I
genuinely do think it's like a gathering
storm type situation like I think people
are organizing their money and their
campaigns and they are thinking about
how to make the most impact both in
terms of
um
just regular regular elections and also
I think a lot of this is going to end up
happening on a kind of ballot initiative
level those take time to organize and
there were already lots of activist
groups uh that work on abortion rights
but frankly I think a lot of them had
gotten a little bit flabby and lazy they
kind of had this pretty good Baseline
and
um you know they were like
knitting hats for people or whatever and
um and now they have to really fight and
I think a lot of those groups if I had
to guess are kind of turning they're
turning their big slow ships I uh think
it's good that there's going to be uh
you know where abortion was on the
ballot one way or the other
pro-choice forces one I think in every
instance I think we're going to see more
of that in 2023 because and this I I
like Catherine I I agree with you
Catherine this should be uh essentially
a fundamental right that should be you
know on some level there should be a
minimum access to abortion through a
certain point in pregnancy that is
National
um but I think we're going to start
getting back to that because what's
going to happen is that most people in
America an overwhelming majority support
some form of choice particularly through
uh you know uh quickening or viability
or you know the first 20 to 25 weeks and
we will now have policies that are going
to I think reflect that because even in
the red Estates and we saw this with
Kansas in particular which was you know
the headquarters of operation rescue uh
you know a famously anti-abortion State
absolutely smacking down you know the
idea that abortion would be banned in uh
in in the Jayhawk state so I think we're
going to see more of that in 2023. yeah
there's also going to be a lot of second
order stuff
um you know I was just reading about uh
in Texas the ban on Telehealth Services
is very tied up in the abortion debate
because they don't want women
getting drugs by mail and having them
administered via Telehealth early in
their pregnancies
um this is the kind of thing that you
don't you the jobs decision comes down
you're not necessarily going to see oh
10 years from now Texas is way behind in
Telehealth but that stuff is coming too
all right let's get to everyone's
predictions
for big story the biggest story perhaps
even of 2023 Dr Nicholas be one elitism
um are we supposed to uh talk about our
failed uh predictions from last year
Matt
um you can maybe take the cues from the
moderator of the podcast just asked you
a question so my prediction yes we are
supposed to you can you can uh you can
put it in there too if you want uh very
quickly the prediction I had last year a
year ago was that uh the GOP would
retake the House and Senate and
definitively cut Trump loose uh clearly
not really right uh you know the the GOP
did take the house lost the Senate
because of that candidate quality you
know morons uh you know we should be
happy that morons don't do that well in
uh in midterm elections
um and but I do think we're seeing the
peeling away of trump his announcement
that he's running you know didn't do
much I think there's a trump core in the
Republican party that will ruin it for
everybody else they're not going
anywhere Trump won't win Trump won't be
the nominee but he will likely destroy
uh whoever the nominee is in 2024 or
custom a lot my my prediction for 2023
Beyond increasing decentralization of
everything is that generational Warfare
is going to be coming uh is going to be
coming into more and more Focus because
it is something that cuts across all
political ideologies and it's becoming
more and more apparent that you know
Boomers and Gen X on the one hand and
Millennials and gen Z have very
different class interests and those are
going to be coming to the fore
particularly as we start running out of
money or prioritizing time in order to
deal with this rather than that Peter
what did you predict last year and what
do you predict I have no idea what I
predicted last year I'm gonna be honest
oh so that link that I see now you could
yeah you could look at options here was
it was that that wasn't preparation
started at around 31 minutes
I need to actually take your hand and
have you click on the link is that is
that the kind of prep this is part of
the generational conflict that you know
I'm talking about because Jen Gen X and
Boomers we get things done whereas these
pasty you know Millennials really we're
really wrapping up the year with Harmony
friendship uh Peter prediction predict
for next year no I remember now I
remember now I remember now I just had a
flashback to this time last year where I
said that nfts would be both more hated
and more useful and that's half true
okay so we're we're we're we're uh 0.5
for two in uh predictions so far but uh
so what do you predict for 2023 I think
that people are going to be talking an
awful lot about section 230 because of
the Supreme Court case because this is
because when this sort of thing goes to
the Supreme Court and the court is going
to have to make a ruling here
um that is going to
start a new era in discourse about
online speech and liability section 230
is best understood as the First
Amendment for the internet right it is
it protects um protects both large
companies and individual users from
liability for things they didn't say
themselves so if you have a comment
section on your sub stack you are not
liable for something that somebody else
says on that because of section 230
that's also why Facebook isn't liable
for something that somebody posts on
Facebook and the Supreme Court is going
to rule about that uh this year and I
think that that is going to bring
a new understanding of what section 230
is and what it does into uh political
discourse a lot of people think that
there is some sort of weird carve out
for big platforms or something like that
it's just wrong there's an awful lot of
bad there are there are an awful lot of
bad legal takes about section 230 out
there and um and I think that especially
in the aftermath of Elon Musk buying
Twitter and what we have seen there and
in the
um in the in Facebook's decline as it is
uh losing daily active users in um in
North America I think that that is
really going to change the discussion
about social media and online speech
Catherine what did you get right
last year and what do you predict for
next I'm right about everything as you
know and I was right about my prediction
which was that it was going to be a big
year of Parental discontent with schools
uh and I I think I use the word
accelerating
um we could quibble with that since um
it is true that there was just a like a
it's hard to actually imagine that
people would have been more discontent
with schools in 2022 than they were in
2021
um but many of the ways in which people
have broken away from or you know kind
of refused to tolerate the shenanigans
of traditional schooling have stuck
around even as other pandemic
restrictions have kind of eased
um the AP did a report
where they looked at homeschooling data
they had 28 States in it and
um
all of those states with the exception
of South Dakota which seems to be a data
issue but all of those States reported
that homeschooling remains significantly
wildly higher than it was pre-pandemic
even though it is down somewhat from the
2020-2021 peak you know this is
Minnesota as an example right so they
had 27 000 students being homeschooled
this year compared with 30 000 during
the last school year but before the
Pandemic those numbers were less than
twenty thousand it's you know that's a
lot of kids
um and
um black families in particular uh are
sticking with homeschooling at extremely
high rates I think this is really
important I was actually just talking
with somebody yesterday
who works in this space about what could
have happened if education savings
accounts had been in place in more
States pre-pandemic because I think a
lot of parents kind of realized that
there were some costs associated with
education choice in its various forms
but especially teaching kids at home and
couldn't absorb those costs especially
in a year when maybe they weren't their
income wasn't what it had previously
been so they ended up going back into
the public system despite being pretty
unhappy with it I do think that's a very
interesting kind of alternate history
where there was just a little pile of
your money your taxpayer money set aside
that you could pull back into your home
to buy books computers fund activities
that kind of thing that is happening in
an increasing number of states and you
know the triple demick didn't really
drive as much as some Public Health
officials hoped it would but I we can't
rule out this happening again and I do I
do have this kind of feeling of like we
should be ready
um but I think broadly my prediction was
right that a lot of people were not
going to go back to public schools and
there was going to be discontent with
the schools this of course doesn't even
begin to address all of the culture war
or you know Public School library book
ban battles Etc
um trans stuff all of which is also
driving
discontent with schools
um prediction for 2023. my prediction
for 2023 is uh I was actually going to
say something a little similar to Peter
so I'll pivot a little bit and say I
think that it's gonna be the year that
this is too stupid to predict yeah I'm
gonna do it okay I think 2023 crypto is
going to redeem itself a little
I I'm not I'm not actually gonna say
like the world will suddenly understand
that uh Bitcoin is the future or
anything like that but I it
I think you know the sambangman freed
stuff and
um you know maybe Associated Elon
Shenanigans to some extent have caused
uh crypto to kind of hit a low point I I
think it's going to come back up I'm not
I'm not speaking to the the value of
people's various crypto Holdings but
instead just to kind of the public
perception of the utility of
cryptocurrency specifically the
blockchain more generally I I feel like
this is the year somebody's gonna figure
out how to use it in a way that doesn't
suck it's going to be like QR codes you
know for so long QR codes were like what
are these garbage things we printed them
in our magazine no one ever used them I
you know I use them four times a week
now four that was my practical purposes
uh so I think
2023 is the year that the crypto makes a
comeback uh might have been your idea
Nick nfts I are gonna have a big year in
2023.
yeah
um sorry Matt the uh kids were talking
what were you saying uh did it it
doesn't matter uh in the long run
um so my prediction from last year which
is basically essentially what
Catherine's was it was uh verbatimly uh
in Fall of 2022 there will be yet
another enrollment declining K-12 that
indeed happened uh it was small but uh
it was uh ongoing to climb the reason
why that's significant in some fashion
is that it was supposed to be a big
bounce back year people were who've been
redshirting their kids we're going to
have them uh uh join Varsity
um and it didn't it didn't happen
um and uh which has pretty profound
implications moving forward right now
the
um prediction for the national Center
for Education statistics is that K-12
total enrollment in the country and this
is a country whose population still
grows uh less so than it used to but
still does is going to go down from a
high from a few years ago of 50 million
down to by 2030 it'll go down to 46
million people are are fleeing um
there's a Washington Post Magazine
article
um back when they had a magazine a month
ago uh with the headline of why are
Americans fleeing Public Schools so they
didn't rebound there are lots of of
implications for cities for policies for
government spending yeah 20 percent of
state and local government spending is
on K-12 schools um and at some point
that becomes politically untenable when
people aren't going there
um to the free school so that was
prediction uh my uh one for 2023
kind of uh picks up where Nick left off
on some level which is I I think it's
going to be something like the Great
Grass Touch of 2023 I think people are
going to uh not just uh you know stop uh
obsessing so much over Twitter not just
kind of uh unplugged from Facebook
that's definitely part of it and those
things are ongoing and kind of had
predated some of the tumult at the end
of the year but I think some of the
passions that people have been pouring
into politics this is a there's a
malaise in this country Nick Gillespie
I'm getting I got a sweater I'm wearing
a cardigan sweater Matt you don't have
to tell me it's not v-neck there's no
elbow patches but it's yeah it's implied
um and a lot of the way that it's that
has been channeled and this is you know
stuff like people's life expectancy has
been going down uh people dropping out
of the workforce just kind of sitting
around playing video games like Peter
suderman uh and uh and like disengaging
from Civic life I think there's going to
be a sense of like the people's
disillusionment with the with the the
side effects of that have been thrown
into politics
for reasons of trump for reasons of
other types of things just because we've
had politics take up this
disproportionate share uh of our minds I
think it's going to be kind of like when
Forrest Gump decides to go running it's
like enough of the 60s I'm just gonna go
run for a while and I'm gonna do some Me
decade stuff
um I think people are going to get out
from and and like buy flip phones there
was a a great article of a trend that
obviously doesn't really exist but uh in
the New York Times a week ago about 25
teenagers in Brooklyn have started the
Luddite society and um and what it is
that'll end well uh so that that must be
sweeping the nation soon but it was
actually very interesting and
heartwarming story of kids who are just
like um let's all get flip phones and
not have smartphones and we will meet
once a week in a park
and we'll talk about books
and uh you read this and you go like I
want to go to the park with the kids and
read a book uh I think people Matt
that's why the police don't allow you
near me what I'm saying is I want to go
back uh screw the restraining order uh
no I think that people are going to be
uh looking for ways to re-engage with
meat space however that is construed and
just trying to consciously uh go back
into community building and away from
Zoom meetings I think the next Zoom
meeting that's going to be suggested is
going to lead to uh there's going to be
a workplace Zoom meeting shooting and I
don't mean Jeffrey Tubman here
um uh it's uh I think he shot himself
Matt he shot himself
the people are gonna go touch grass is
uh uh I don't know exactly how it's
going to be reflected in gigantic
statistics but uh I think it'll be more
front of mind uh all right I just want
to very quickly point out an epic
phenomenon of this Forrest Gump uh
moment is going to be a Resurgence in
the Life and Legacy of Mr Bob Seger
uh because that's who forest was singing
uh was running to he was running Against
the Wind damn right you damn 2023 is
looking pretty damn fine
23. until this moment and now I'm not
anymore
how long have you been saving that one
um Catherine please please fire
everybody on this podcast
um all right let's go to our end of
podcast uh usually like what are we
consuming but what was the thing that we
all consumed in the cultural sphere that
had the most
impact on us personally Nick so what
drug uh would you say is the one oh yeah
I'm still on it but I've forgotten what
it was it was so powerful Matt yeah you
know so that's a real mystery I'm hoping
to solve that in a future episode but my
consumption of the year uh surprising to
me when you asked this question because
I would have thought it I could have
thought of a couple things but think
about it I had mentioned Fred Lewis
Frederick Lewis Allen's the big change
America transforms itself 1900 to 1950
which was originally published in 1952
and it's the story of how America went
from being a rural relatively poor
country to an industrialized relatively
rich country that was also a global
hegemon and that stuck with me because I
am more convinced than ever and I you
know I've been trying this out Workshop
this endlessly for the past 10 years
that we are in the long 20th century
we're in the grasp of that and we are
struggling to actually get to the next
era in American life and Alan's book
helped me kind of helps me think about
that but I think we are at the end of an
era and that era might be the late 60s
uh when reason was founded uh the uh or
when the era began or it might be 1989
or 1991 when the Cold War ended but
whatever era we're in and we see this in
politics this is the the beginning point
of the Declaration of Independence uh
the book that we wrote together met to
remind people including the other two
people on this podcast who seemingly
have never heard of it but I think we're
um you know that has stuck with me
because I think we are finally getting
to that next stage
um and a lot of the themes that we're
talking about here we're in a new era
where people are going to be focused on
and consumed by new things as opposed to
you know the end of the general I mean
what's good about this is the end of the
gerontocracy Nancy Pelosi is already out
of office Biden will be out of office
Trump is gone the gerontocracy is
finally dying off and a terrible beauty
is born to uh paraphrase or to actually
directly quote W.B Yates
um Catherine what kind of Terrible
Beauty have you been consuming
have you been birthing
I uh looked back through the handy dandy
page where we keep all of the reason
Roundtable recommendations you can find
it on our website or by Googling fans of
the Round Table
um and uh I mean real talk I did
recommend e-scooters is like a cool
thing in 2022. so what's in your
prediction that went horribly wrong it
was your recommendation yeah so
obviously my broken kneecap uh begs to
differ on that recommendation and it is
both literally and figuratively probably
the most impactful consumption that I
have done in 2022. are you sharing a gag
Rider with suderman now
writing for you guys or something
is it going dutch on a joke writer
um but uh if you are looking for
a recommendation or something to consume
uh the school for good Mothers which I
recommended uh back at the beginning of
the year is definitely the book I read
that haunts me the most it is a kind of
skinasian dystopia about
um parenting in a surveillance State and
um
that book kind of messed me up so uh
that's a recommendation I think
um you know when when something is when
something kind of Pops back into your
mind weeks and months after you read it
um
it was a good book so uh the school for
good Mothers which is a not very long
novel by Jasmine Chan
um
read it if you want to be sad this
Christmas
and who doesn't want to be sad suderman
what uh
what's sad making cocktail
consumption of the year
this was a genuinely hard uh call
because I saw a bunch of great movies I
saw a bunch of great concerts came very
close to recommending everything
everywhere all at once uh which is maybe
not the best movie I've seen this year
exactly but probably the one that I
enjoyed the most but uh no I'm actually
gonna go with the most obvious thing
that I could recommend
Star Wars Andor
which is the best Star Wars thing I've
seen since I was a little kid when I
watched first watched Empire Strikes
Back it is the smartest most satisfying
um most consistent and best looking Star
Wars uh and really one of the best
looking and smartest big franchise
Productions of any kind in MCU the DC
Comics Universe uh you know the even the
Game of Thrones expanded universe that
we saw grow out this year
I don't think there was another show
that I looked forward to as much as this
one so it's maybe not the best thing I
watched but it was the most satisfying
the most comforting
um the thing that I that I really just
wanted to sit down and watch every time
there was a new episode and the thing
that I will probably be thinking about
uh
or at least a thing that I will be
thinking about
um for for quite a while just because
it's so well executed and it really
shows I think the promise
um of of big expanded universes and big
franchises to tell intricate political
stories that um that gold surprising
places like I said a couple weeks ago on
this podcast when I when I first talked
about it it's a it's a series that casts
the Rebellion against the empire as uh
effectively as a right-wing
anti-government group funded by
non-profit dark money through uh through
a senator who is who is you sort of
lying about her complicity and and uh
doing dirty deals with um you know with
uh maybe skeezy bankers and it's like
that's not the story I would have uh I
would have expected from from a a
franchise that has mostly been you know
campbell-esque hero's journey adventure
stories um but it's really effective and
really good and I'm very much looking
forward to the next season by far the
most uh impact any piece of anything has
had on me this year was reading a
post-war by Tony jutt
um jute a history of Europe since 1945
is published in 2005 when uh a passel of
uh awards for historiography and book
awards and and whatnot it is just a
tremendous and comprehensive account of
uh firstly just how broken everything
was at the end of World War II in Europe
uh gives you a sense of perspective that
is just uh uh always lacking when people
start making claims about such and such
thing being the uh the worst thing
that's happened since World War II no
dude the next six years were pretty
rough especially the next like uh two or
three uh that was first became
interested in the history of
post-wareness issue issues by being an
ignoramus American in Central Europe in
the early 1990s and learning about the
benesh decrees Eduardo benesch's exiled
government in London from Czechoslovakia
Czechoslovakia not the world's biggest
country expelled three million people
after the war uh some of them expelled
by executing them like 20 000 Germans
because there had been a bunch of ethnic
Germans in the sudenten land
um that was the labens realm area they
had reason to be upset with some of
their citizens but also hungarians who
had been living in those areas of
Slovakia for centuries uh just expelled
um and it it gives you a sense the book
does of the massive the difficulties of
of settling uh post-war situation
figuring out population exchanges
borders security guarantees gives you I
think respect for the institution
building that happened afterwards
um that was a frantic frantic season of
institution building in terms of the
United Nations uh uh the World Bank a
bunch of different things that cropped
up uh immediately after a Marshall Plan
as part of that
um uh defending Berlin
um all these things
um it gives you a uh uh almost a uh a
Pang of thinking about how the current
moment of populism is in many ways a
revolt against those institutions or a
desire to refresh them and they all need
refreshing if not in some cases
eradication
um but it was a pretty interesting
season back then and thankfully when we
don't have exactly right now there's so
much more wealth and it the main thrust
of the book is actually about how uh the
the kind of miraculous Revival of
Western Europe and how that happened
um but also it's just a very difficult
uh tricky time with usually so many
crises have happening simultaneously
that it makes our you know current
concerns seem a pretty small uh in uh in
comparison
um just a really great and and uh
thought-provoking piece of comprehensive
history if you're interested in Europe
and foreign relations and War and people
and and the and and d uh colonization or
colonialization of the great colonial
empires as well so anyways post-war Tony
jut history of Europe since 1945. check
it out all right let's go uh now and say
our goodbye say farewell
um to 2022 and thank you for listening
for all of it if you like our stuff
think about uh giving a tax deductible
year-end donation a reason.com donate
our podcasts live at a reason.com
podcasts uh and thank you we'll see you
in 2023. goodbye
[Music]
trying
[Music]